- Hello, I would
like to purchase a
delicious drink from you.
- Uh, yeah, I'm sorry,
I didn't know anyone
else was still here.
We closed like two hours ago.
- I would like a drink,
heavy with alcohol.
You must be wondering why.
Thank you for asking.
I've had a long stressful
day at the office.
Crunching and grinding
and now I want my
blood diluted, my brain slowed
by your sweet liquid caress.
- Ah, I see.
Well, you know, we got a,
a really great bar
down the street
that does, uh, blood dilution.
- Inside of me is an
aching need, writhing,
dancing, years of droughts
have caused a desert
and now I stand here begging.
- Well, well I'm gonna go make a
phone call real quick.
(crunching)
- The doors of my home
have been shuttered.
And guess what?
Baby's not allowed in
the hospital anymore.
And so baby wanders,
looking for mommy.
But mommy isn't there,
(voice raising) Not
at this time of night.
The blood of my family
pools around my feet.
(voice deepening) And so
I stand here, waiting.
- You know I,
if you wanna drink, that's fine.
I'll get you a
drink, no problem.
- Serve me, touch me,
serve me, touch me,
(voice raising) serve
me, serve me, serve me!
- Please don't hurt me!
(light music)
- (child's voice)
Oh, this looks yummy!
Thank you, Mister.
I'm sorry about being so weird.
I just really needed this.
(cheerful humming)
- Yeah, we're still closed.